Welcome to Hannity. It's time for the
world to wake up. In just the past four
months, we have seen a sharp spike in
the number of radical Islamic terror
attacks around the world, including
right here on American soil. Watch this.
Sounds like he's running around out
here.
And the gunshot
tonight. Terror in the heartland. The
FBI is investigating a brutal beheading
in Moore, Oklahoma
after the suspect's co-workers revealed
that he had been trying to convert them
to Islam.
He did kill Colleen and did sever her
head.
Canada now where there has been a
shooting
at Parliament Hill, which is now in
complete lockdown.
The suspect is still on the loose. This
is an active shooting situation.
A man with apparent sympathies toward
anti-American rhetoric is dead tonight
after attacking a group of New York City
police officers with a hatchet.
Preliminary evaluation is is to dispose
of each other's assets.
Sydney, Australia. Hostages seen on
camera running for their lives.
Five people escaping from a gunman who
some 15 hours ago stormed into a cafe in
downtown Sydney waving a jihadi flag.
[Music]
[Applause]
A massive manhunt underway right now in
Paris for the masked gunman, three of
them, who stormed a French newspaper,
killing at least 12 people at the
offices of Charlie Abdo.
This vicious terrorist attack
is a reminder that we must always be
vigilant
against the enemies of freedom.
Now, the rise of radical Islam around
the globe is disturbing. So, tonight we
have brought together right here in
studio terrorism experts, former members
and law enforcement officials and much
more to talk about this grave threat.
Thank you all for being with us.
Appreciate it. Robert Spencer, Jihad
Watch. Seems that um we have this rise,
but there is one commonality in each
instance. the word Islam, but yet we the
president won't say Islamic State. What
happened at Fort Hood, Alahu Akbar is uh
is workplace violence. Why this
reluctance and resistance to say the
word Islam and associate with terror? It
seems as if the president thinks and the
administration thinks that if they say
something is Islamic, then they will be
at war with the entire Islamic world and
right-wing racist vigilantes will go and
victimize innocent people in the United
States. Both are hogwash and nonsense.
And what's happened is that we have
effectively gotten into gotten ourselves
into a position where it's forbidden to
speak about the motives and goals of the
enemy. And you cannot possibly defeat an
enemy that you refuse to understand.
You know, I had Andrew Chowy on the
radical imam. What did he say? I said,
"Well, is Islam a peaceful religion?" He
said, "No, it's not. It's about
submission." Is that the interpretation?
And how many people are we talking
about? Well, the word Islam itself means
submission. It does not mean peace. It's
related to peace, but it means
submission. And it not only means
submission to God, it means submission
of the non-Muslims to the Muslims. It is
a political system that mandates that
the non-Muslims have to live in a state
of subordination under the rule of Islam
and are denied basic rights.
That is exactly what the imam said to me
this week. Very open and honest. And I
actually I wanted people to hear that. I
came under some fire for putting him on
and giving him airtime. Bill Donnier,
you're with the Catholic League. We keep
hearing, well, they're extremists in in
every religion. I don't you you dealt
with the issue of the Virgin Mary
painting with elephant dung and a
crucifix submerged in urine. Did any
Christians go out there and kill because
of those expressions?
No. That's because we exercise the
virtue of restraint, which obviously
doesn't is not widespread in the Muslim
community. And it's not just the radical
Muslims. It it may be only a few that
are violent, but quite frankly, the
support for blasphemy laws in Sharia
extends way beyond just just these
barbarians that we're talking about.
Yeah. Lieutenant General McCannernney,
let me ask you, um, do you think
militarily the United States is handling
this properly? We do we taking Islam,
radical Islam, seriously enough that
we'll defeat it, or are we appeasing it?
Did the French appease the Muslims that
moved by giving them their no-go zones,
their own private neighborhood and
territory? Is that the right decision?
Well, uh I would say we are not even
appeasing it right now. Right now we are
losing. We haven't lost, but we are
losing. And that's because our military
leaders do not know the enemy. As Suns
Sue says, "Know thy threat." Well,
you're going to hear senior military
leaders in active duty now, they talk
about radical extremists. Sean, tell me
what is the ideology of a radical
extremist? I'll tell you what the
ideology of a radical Islamist is. It's
the Quran, it's Sharia, and it's the
Hadith. That's where they get their
rules of engagement and their ideology.
And so, if we don't identify the
radicals for what they are and where it
came from, we cannot defeat it. And the
military today is not identifying it.
Let's talk about Breiji. You um you
lived in Pakistan, right?
I lived in Lebanon.
Lebanon. Okay. and you understand, you
studied the Quran. Let's take the
literal interpretation of the Quran,
infidels, jihad,
the the things that are in there. If
taken literally, does that lead to what
Robert Spencer is talking about?
Uh, yes, that's exactly what they lead
to. Jihad against the infidels. We have
a saying in Arabic,
first come Saturday, then come Sunday.
First we kill the Jews, then we come for
the Christians. In the middle, the
Islamic Middle East, there is no
tolerance to any other faith or group of
people. Uh we minorities in the Middle
East have been massacred, killed. Uh my
house was bombed. This is how I ended up
in this country as a refugee from the
Middle East. It was happening when my
parents were refugees when I was a
child, newborn, and here I am in America
today and my people are still fleeing
because of the intolerance of Islamic
extremism. So my past is America's
future unless America wakes up now and
takes the necessary steps.
What are the necessary What are the
necessary steps?
Identify the enemy by name in order for
you to devise a strategy to defeat it.
Right now we have a president at the
White House who doesn't have the moral
clarity and the courage to stand up and
say what we are fighting. And we need to
do that in order for us to defeat this
enemy. It is Islamic terrorism. It's not
Buddhist terrorism. It's not Jewish
terrorism. It's not Catholic terrorism.
How many How many numbers are we talking
about? Does the world has 1.6 billion
Muslims? How many Muslims are we talking
about?
We're talking about 1.2 billion Muslims
in the world today. 15 to 25% are
radicalized.
You're talking about 400 million maybe.
We're talking about 300 million people
who are ready to strap bombs on their
bodies and blow us all up to smitherine.
And what about the others? Are they in a
silent agreement or are they afraid that
they will be deemed apostates and
aposticism under Islam is death?
The majority agree with the radicals.
The Pure Research did a study back in
2013, just almost a year ago, where they
interviewed Muslims from around the
world, Indonesia, Bangladesh, Nairobi,
uh Pakistan, all over the Islamic world,
Egypt. And what they found out is the
top five Islamic countries, Indonesia,
Nairobi, Bangladesh, Pakistan, Egypt,
the the average 77% support the
establishment of Sharia Allah as the law
of the state and the establishment of an
Islamic caliphate.
All right. So now we've got 44 million
Benjamin Muslims in Europe. 44 million.
That's expected to grow to 58 million uh
in the next 15 years. Now we see how
France has a problem. Belgium has a
problem all throughout Europe. Great
Britain has a problem. They set up no go
zones. No non-Muslims not allowed.
Separate Sharia courts. Police can't
even go in if there's an issue or
firemen can't go in. So now the question
is, okay, if you're a western country
and Sharia is contradictory to all of
those values. So Muslims are moving in.
How do you determine which Muslims want
freedom and which maybe perhaps want to
come in and implement Sharia law? How do
these western countries decide who gets
in and who doesn't get in?
Well, so I think that there's a social
contract that has to exist, right,
between the immigrant and the country of
of that they're that they're coming to.
Um I think we certainly believe that
here in the US. Um I think one of the
issues that we've now seen the
consequence of in France, as you as you
said, France is the largest Muslim
population in Europe, 6.5 million. You
know, that's 10% of their of their
population. that has led to them
becoming a very large uh active
constituency. Right? So, uh President
Holland won 93% of that vote um of the
of that 6.5 million. That's a very
important voting block. So, they now
have gone from these very disperate kind
of you know organizations.
They have voting power.
They have voting power which means that
they have massive amounts of influence
which means you know how much
so they literally they go to France.
They don't assimilate. They take
portions of the country unto themselves
and say don't come into our part.
Yes sir.
That's the See, Pam, you you are very
outspoken in terms of the Israeli
Palestinian conflict and groups like
Hamas and Hezbollah, Islamic Jihad, the
Muslim Brotherhood. It sounds to me like
France has almost set itself up where
like Israel, they will be surrounded
very closely uh by neighbors that want
to destroy them. Is that what is the be
is this the beginning of something to
come?
Well, perhaps they should meet with the
French Muslims and set up two states so
they can live side by side peacefully.
Um, that's a joke.
I I could tell.
Uh, but but look,
but it's not a joke because they're
living separately.
No, they are living separately. Police
can't go in there. They are ambushed.
It's like almost, you know, hundreds of
years ago where there were city states
set up. I don't worry so much about the
the piety and the the devoutness of the
enemy. I worry about the confusion and
the obfuscation on our side. The New
York Times actually scrubbed the news
story where one of the jihadists told
the journalists that lived that she had
to convert. She had to study the Quran
and she had to wear the veil. They took
that they removed that from the story.
The editor took it out of the story.
This is very important. We're going to
talk about the media later.
Yeah. Well, the media
we'll get to know on this. I know he's a
media expert. They took it out of the
story.
It's obuscation. It's deliberate. It's
it's it's it's the enemy media. I mean,
they're literally deceiving and
disarming freedom loving peoples. Ismael
Brinsley, who slaughtered the New New
York Police Department, his Facebook
page, Strike Terror in the Hearts uh of
the infidel, the the beheader, uh
Israel, uh who beheaded Colleen
Huffford, who you started out with, his
Facebook page was all Islam. That was
not in the paper.
How many agree with what Pam's saying?
So, the world So, let me ask the
question another way, maybe uh more
bluntly. Is the world cowering to Islam?
Hands hands up.
Everybody agrees? Anyone disagree?
Anybody disagree?
Wow. Pretty interesting. All right, we
got to take a break. We're going to come
back and coming up next on this busy
news night tonight here on Hannity.
Welcome back to the special audience
edition of Hannity, the rise of radical
Islam. Now, last week the radical London
imam Anjam Chowdery was a guest on this
program. He gave his definition of what
Islam is. Take a close listen.
Islam does not mean peaceful. It means
submission. Submission to the commands
of God. He want of me. Then we can live
peacefully together.
Now unlike Chowy, many Muslims describe
theirs as a religion of peace. But some
verses from the Quran tell a very
different story. Let's take a look at
the Quran. Quote, "So when you meet
those who disbelieve in battle, strike
their necks until you have inflicted
slaughter upon them." Here's another.
But those who disbelieve will have cut
out for them garments on fire. Pour upon
their heads will be scalding water which
is melted that within their bellies and
their skins. And here's what the Quran
says about other religions. The Jews say
that Ezra is the son of Allah. And the
Christians say the Messiah is the son of
Allah. Well, that is their statement
from their mouths. And it goes on to
read, may Allah destroy them. Uh how are
they deluded? But there are moderate
voices in Islam. For example, here is
Egyptian President Abdel Fatah Elsisi
speaking to imams and religious
scholars. Listen closely to what he said
this past Christmas.
We bring back our studio audience.
Robert, that's where we started. The the
Quran Rashid, that's where we started.
So is that how the you're saying 300
million Muslims interpret the Quran that
literally?
Estimated 300 million Muslims out of the
1.2 billion who follow the teachings of
the Quran and believe it literally to
the word and they want to follow it.
How many people agree that that is the
interpretation of as many as 300 million
or more?
It's many more than that.
500 million. I thought it was 1.6
billion. Well, 300 million may be
willing to actually go out and kill, but
the literalism is the mainstream
understanding of the Quran in Islam.
There is no developed tradition of
interpreting these things in some
figurative way. When the Quran says
fight against the people of the book,
that's Jews and Christians, until they
pay the Jiza attacks with willing
submission and feel themselves subdued,
that is taught as a mandate for warfare
by the vast majority by virtually all
Islamic authorities.
General, it's it's mainstream. The
Muslims who are not fighting still
understand that that is something that
is good and proper to be done and they
applaud those who do it.
General is I understand the military
knows this but I only think it's
beginning to dawn on people. Everyone
here in this room has read the Quran or
at least portions of it
and what Yeah. And I I would assume the
military knows full well what's in
there. But do you think the average
American does?
Well, first of all, average American
doesn't. But the average military man
doesn't either. They have really
restricted the study of radical Islam.
They don't even use that term. Anything
in their curriculum that talks about
radical Islam has been eradicated with
this administration. And that is our
main problem. And and our leadership,
look, the captains, the majors, the
sergeants understand that the Iraqis,
etc. did not want our Jeffersonian
democracy. They wanted our money. Mhm.
But
President Obama scrubbed all of the
materials that that General McInner is
talking about. Robert Spencer used to
talk to Intel. They're not getting any
education whatsoever. What General Cece
said was calling for a revolution in
it's calling for a revolution in Islam.
That you
he may die for those comments,
but but saying you got to change. Your
President Obama did not die. He backed
the Muslim Brotherhood. He backed the he
backed the opposition to this man that's
speaking frankly and candidly about
Islam.
Sean, this this brings a bigger issue.
Is the issue Islam as a whole for
failing to police itself? We need to
look at that as a country.
David, there there's a very important
point to come off what Carl just said.
We can fight this problem. We can kill
terrorists and we should kill as many as
possible at every opportunity. But it's
up to the Muslims around the world to
police and solve their problem. And and
frankly this will be a violent solution.
Muslims will have to kill Muslims by the
tens of thousands by the millions to
solve this issue.
Yeah. I think what what the general was
talking about is really a failure of our
understanding geopolitically. In 2001 it
was it was unfathomable that you could
see an establishment of a caliphate
across North Africa and into the Middle
East. Today it is a reality. We're
looking at a geopolitical a real war,
not an in counterinsurgency operation
like we saw in the last decade.
Let me go to Hang on, Lisa. Leah, Andy.
Yeah.
Yeah. I I just wanted to say that that
that uh I I actually went with Robert to
uh to Fort Levvenworth at one point. And
the same academic resistance that you
see toward towards understanding and
teaching the jihad ideology that you
would see in the Ivy League at a
Harvard, for example, where you would
understand it because it's a hard-left
institution. That is in the military
institutions as well. you were fighting.
I think I'm just going to have to
correct the record here about the
military and the intelligence community
because I served in both. And to say
that that there's not an understanding
of violent extremism and terrorism in
those communities.
It's jihad. It's not violent extremism.
It's jihad. Okay? It's rooted in Islam.
It is it is how the Muslim Empire was
created and it's how it's it's how it
has no play tit for tat here. to to say
that the intelligence community does not
understand and is not focused on is
absolutely wrong. If you listen to the
testimony, if you listen to the
testimony of the director of the
National Counterterrorism Center and the
director of the FBI, these are things
that they are looking at. They're things
they're watching and it's things the
intelligence community have been
watching for. The counterinsurgency
manual is completely separate from the
intelligence community. I'm sorry. We're
going to have to we're going to have
this was such a peaceful show. Muslim
organizations wrote to John Brennan on
October 19th, 2011 demanding that all of
Islam be removed from
We got to take a break. We'll come back
in just a moment. More Hannity straight
ahead.